To the shoulder or to the biceps and the animal like this to the elbow to the
shoulder.
Different.
No,
no,
no.
You have to do it.
We're talking fricking ongoing abuse.
Number one.
No,
no,
no.
Well,
dream.
And then you come right back.
DMT.
If you hate that shit.
James is on point as well.
Let's get serious.
Let's get Siri just share a few things before he goes down this road.
Okay.
These are the,
what are the rope?
But I wasn't going down.
I'll roll.
We just talking about,
we know what the road is there talking about George Soros.
No,
no,
no.
We passed that.
Well,
we just talking about,
uh,
you were talking about the Strip club.
The Guy Choking the girl,
the girl truck and the guy out.
The Guy Falling and hitting his head.
And then what happened after that?
Any ideas,
Jamie?
No one.
Everyone's stupid for that one or that one time I got choked out.
I remember watching the babies.
I remember one time it was,
it was cool.
I don't think I've ever been choked completely out of 35 seconds.
The first time I got chucked out,
it was like the 17 year old super hot chick and I was like 13 tied up and she
lived down the street.
No,
no.
She goes,
I already,
I got permission so I was pretty young like 12 and she goes,
I'll have sex with you.
It was a true story.
I'll have sex with you if you let me put makeup on you so I'm not in the gates.
Everything show the girl puts the makeup on it as sex with her and she's super
hot and then like a week later she goes,
now I'm going to choke you out.
In that relationship went really well until like 30 year old boyfriend caught me
at her place wants cause her mom was always working and trying to kill me in the
parking lot.
Oh my God,
I'll have sex with you.
I can put makeup on you.
I let her go full deal.
You listen,
you're a wise man.
She can.
That bitch can dress me up like a clown.
Here's some of the things I have and then we'll get to go forever.
He goes,
not conspiracies,
but real world programs developing a breakaway civilization.
What does a breakaway civilization?
You understand that it's the key to everything.
Standardized total surveillance,
control grid,
the power.
Despise the power control.
Human animal hybrids.
We recover that.
Mass farming of humanoid tissue transhuman end game.
We come into and multilayered binary weapons delivery systems.
That's when we haven't had,
oh what's that?
Well,
we'll get into some of that.
The pain is five g behavioral modifications.
We hit that Trojan horse delivery system,
cell phones,
vaccines.
Gmos have been tested and designed to hurt you.
Again,
vaccines are real.
You can give somebody something that gives them the cure.
Another disease that doesn't yet,
but they're jacking it like a cell phone.
They're adding stuff in your ticket to immortality that we think so.
Let's cover that.
What do you think is happening with vaccines?
I know,
okay,
tell me what's going on.
I always use this cause everyone's heard of it.
Everyone heard about 1947 to 1983 and it only came public because the program
was exposed in Peru and promote disclosed in West Virginia.
But the media picked up because it was white on black,
not all the white people that happened to,
I don't care if you're black or white,
injecting over a million people with live syphilis in the name of vaccines.
You know about Tuskegee that do know about that.
But you only know about Alabama and over 40 something years only injecting
blacks.
But it happened all the world search engine.
Hillary Clinton apologizes for syphilis experiments in Tuskegee.
It was [inaudible].
It was,
it was in Peru.
Can I ask you,
this was the Tuskegee was the,
um,
the conventional story that they had syphilis but they weren't really curing
them.
That's a cover.
No,
but it's not what they say if you actually read it.
they were giving him selfless.
Okay.
I understand what you're saying.
But was the,
the,
the conventional explanation of what happened was that,
that they knew that they had it and they allowed them to know that was the
[inaudible] came out.
Okay.
Have you heard about hearing this right there us apologizes for Guatemala,
STD experiments.
They did all the different ones.
Just type Peru,
ruin medic.
Hold on.
Gift him for in this.
Can you make that a little goats scroll up so I can read it.
A U s government medical researchers intentionally infected hundreds of people
in Guatemala including institutionalized mental patients with gonorrhea and
syphilis without their knowledge or permission more than 60 years ago.
Jesus Christ.
Show Joe again.
Um,
when you've read,
cause what I do is,
oh Jesus Christ.
Look at this.
Many of those infected.
We're encouraged to pass the infection.
As you judge as part of the study,
where does this end?
What is NBC News?
Imagine finding out you have syphilis but you've never had sex before.
Let me stop.
Let me,
Shaw's is gone and you imagine how confusing are you ready for another ultra
secret since this 46 to what?
46 two sorry.
It says at the [inaudible] 69,
1948 God damn.
Nine 46 months.
That's all I watched.
That's not okay.
It's not two years.
Okay.
She'll,
she'll,
she'll let me expand
then.
Imagine Joe,
here's what's happened.
Okay.
We had a real liberal media in this country.
They weren't leftist.
That's,
that's a cultic that's different.
We had a real liberal media in this country that had problems,
but they really cared.
They were open minded.
When I said Delta has done information a few years after I proved Delta Force
was and she had one and [inaudible] 99 and proved it.
They all shed.
Alex Jones just ride.
It's incredible.
That's the WTO tape that I always cite that tight that we showed.
The agent provocateurs went into a peaceful protest and started smashing windows
and I'm not against the army,
but Delta Force rent because I always go,
oh no,
the army's terrorist.
Like you should.
I don't call it the whole garden meant a select group of the army did that.
They staged it.
Show,
imagine use to the,
the press would get a lot of stuff right,
but they would get demoted or whatever.
What happened once Trump got in,
which I don't think Trump's pad and a gut level that he's good,
but I almost think like it's more sophisticated.
They putting them in knowing it piss everybody off to get the liberals who
traditionally have been the real watchdogs free speech and against human
experimentation and suddenly they're like in Gallup polls,
we love war.
We love experimentation.
We love everything.
I'm getting chills right now and so imagine Joe,
I've been on air for 23 years and I'm a news hound.
I spend four or five hours a day reading news,
so I will probably leave NBC news that our government gave people.
Notice I said Peru because that was a big document,
a case you just found Guatemala,
different things.
He track of this.
We'll just went under the A's.
It's still going on,
so imagine,
imagine I have literally by the time Sandy Hook happens,
I've literally seen 10,000 articles and documents are more where they're
admitting.
In 1962 the joint chiefs of staff under Llm,
Sir came to President Kennedy.
This was on PBS and said,
we're going to blow up buildings.
Shoot up schools and movie theaters and bomb army bases and marine basis.
We're going to have people with their kids with name change and or CIA get on a
jumbo jet.
The techs off it gets blown up over the Caribbean.
We blame Cuba,
but that plane really lands and there's another plane that's a drone.
We blow up and then Kennedy says,
no,
but his brother says,
I'll do.
It's why they killed Kennedy because Bobby said he would,
but then he got pissed when they killed his brother sold declassified.
He wanted to bomb the Honduran embassy and blow up stuff and go to war with
Moscow.
Bobby was bad.
You could actually,
this is,
you can pull this up,
pull up.
Bobby Kennedy wanted to bomb the u s embassy in Honduras.
This is declassified.
And so imagine you see hundreds of these and then a sandy hook happens and your
listeners don't buy it and then it's a psychosis where then,
well,
because every,
every man I knew,
and this is hypothetical debate,
that was great.
Every man I knew when I was a kid backhanded me and beat the crap out of me.
So men are bad or a woman that's been raped.
She takes all men are bad show.
I get like the psychosis and I'm not trying to put myself down like I'm a
victim.
I'm being honest.
Retrospectively that got to where when I learned that so much stuff was false.
Then later I experienced where I had the guest.
I did the thing,
I knew it was true and then people made up a whole story because they don't
believe anything anymore.
So that's all I'm trying to say.
Do you think it part of it is that even though this stuff does exist,
it's almost like there's too many things happening for one person to pay
attention to all of them.
And if you're only focusing on emotional overload,
if you're only,
but hold on,
if you're only focusing on that aspect of life,
it can be incredibly overwhelming cause you start thinking that's the whole
world that the whole world's these conspiracies cause these are the things
you're concentrating on primarily.
But this,
this what I'm saying?
That's his,
he just talked about operation Northwoods,
that whole thing.
Yeah.
Operation Northwoods.
That is some,
that's about as ABC,
that's about us.
That's true.
Clear as day clear.
But if you break it down and you look at it and say,
you look at Operation Northwoods,
you look at that shit that is about as gangster and sinister and evil as we went
over just a little while ago,
we were going into totally.
My point is if you believe that no other conspiracy theory,
whether they're right or wrong,
like government conspiracy should be ridiculed.
You shouldn't,
there's no,
there should be no ridicule.
You're right.
You should,
instead of looking at them with riveter,
cool.
You should look at them objectively and event.
Exactly.
And the only,
the only people that have a right to ridicule a conspiracy theories are people
that don't believe in any conspiracy theories.
If you don't believe in any of them,
yes,
I understand why you're really killing it people all the time to leave them.
Some of them,
if you believe in some of them,
the other ones you don't believe in.
I think you should be more.
Uh,
I don't believe in that shit,
but I understand why my defense almost now almost we could probably get the
store on a cord.
I'm also looking forward to trial in Texas and,
and Connecticut because I want to,
and the Lord has already agreed.
I'm going to sit there and I'm going to show them history and all these things
and say like,
I mean,
I watched the,
uh,
it's already been out for like a year or two,
but I watched the minions three or four and it's like in the 60s.
And they break it down to the set of Hollywood and the moon landings being
staged now.
Now astronauts died doing that.
So how traumatic is that for their family?
But I believe that [inaudible]
we're going to have to in a minute.
Wait,
wait.
Astronauts done which ones?
Oh,
a space shuttle.
When we're going to talk about it.
No,
no,
they just,
the bus from Apollo launchpad
was talking to one or not
practicing.
Yes,
they were practicing.
I'm curious.